alors aujourd'hui c'est comment la vie
Jérôme
de la nuit au jour
et du samedi 20h ce soir Jérôme à mon
bonsoir
alors Jérôme il y a un an et demi le
monde de la médecine était secoué par un
exploit chirurgical exceptionnel au CHU
Henri-Mondor de Créteil le professeur
Lantieri venait de réaliser la première
greffe totale de la face c'est une
première mondiale le bénéficiaire
c'était vous Jérôme vous étiez atteint
de neurofibromatose qui détruisait votre
visage depuis plus de 15 ans cette
greffe dites-vous à transformer ma
fatalité en espoir
Jérôme maman rebonsoir
vous êtes né le 30 janvier 1975 à
Landivisiau dans le Finistère vous êtes
le deuxième d'une famille de trois
enfants père moniteur d'auto-école mère
agent de la Caisse Primaire d'Assurance
Maladie
dès votre naissance vous présenter un
problème de santé inhabituel pour un
nouveau-né Vous avez un glaucome à
l'oeil droit il faut vous retirer l'oeil
droit et vous mettre une prothèse alors
ce qu'on ne sait pas à l'époque c'est
qu'il s'agit du premier signe de votre
maladie la neurofibromatose ou maladie
de raclinghausen mais à l'époque
personne ne détecte cette maladie alors
après l'opération donc vous retrouvez
une vie normale et à part cette prothèse
oculaire jusqu'à l'âge de 9 ans vous
n'avez aucun autre signe de la maladie
en fait mais vers 9 ans le côté droit de
votre visage commence à se déformer la
peau s'affaisse et les traits changent
oui alors tout ce que l'on sait
effectivement à l'époque c'est que la
maladie
est incurable et que les déformations
s'accélèrent quand le moral du patient
faibli donc le seul remède finalement
c'est l'optimisme et vous dites dans la
famille on en parlait pas la maladie
était absolument tabou on continue à
vivre comme si de rien n'était en fait
voilà moi déjà je refusé d'en parler
tout simplement parce que je n'y
arrivais pas à mettre une
ça c'est une maladie et il était
difficile pour moi d'exprimer ce que je
ressentais en 1985 j'ai 10 ans quand
vous subissez votre premier opération de
chirurgie réparatrice en fait une sorte
de lifting on vous tire la peau pour
reconstruire en fait la symétrie du
visage exactement alors vous subirez une
dizaine de ces opérations en disant sans
grands résultats la maladie gagnée du
terrain d'une certaine façon c'était pas
oui c'est pas très productif disons
exactement puisque les
opérations en question était efficaces
pendant quelques mois
mais après la maladie prenez le dessus
était là alors en arrivant au collège
vous découvrez l'impact de votre
différence sur les relations humaines et
là c'est terrible effectivement parce
que les enfants sont extrêmement cruels
ils vous appellent l'éléphant man il
vous appelle Quasimodo
vous vous réfugiez dans le sport mais le
sport solitaire dans le cyclisme en fait
d'échapper complètement et ça allait
toujours
d'échapper complètement quotidien et
c'était un moyen effectivement de
me prouver que j'étais capable de faire
les choses comme n'importe qui
quant aux filles alors vous comprenez
rapidement effectivement que leur
gentillesse n'est qu'une mascarade et
quand on vous dit en amour le physique
ne compte pas vous comprenez bien que
c'est un mensonge quoi
on a on a une photo de de vous justement
avant l'opération voilà
évidemment le regard des autres
une torture pour vous il y a un jour
assez terrible que vous n'avez pas
oublié c'est qu'avec votre famille un
dimanche après midi vous rendez visite à
un taxi dermiste qui reproduit des
scènes de la nature
et ce type là en fait dit à vos parents
c'est vachement bien de s'occuper d'un
trisomique et ça c'est quelque chose que
aujourd'hui les 37 ans vous n'avez pas
oublié quoi entendre ça c'est désormais
et que répondre donc la douleur elle est
restée en nous et on n'arrivait pas à
l'esprimer et d'être une manière
d'exprimer à qui
vous obtenez malgré tout votre bac vous
trouvez un job dans un laboratoire de
biologie un IUT à Versailles mais votre
vision monoculaire est un compatible
avec le travail en laboratoire donc vous
ne pouvez pas rester vous trouverez
finalement votre voix dans l'audiovisuel
après avoir passé le concours de l'estra
vous devenez intermittent du spectacle
vous bossez pour Eurodisney vous bossez
pour des théâtres vous bossez pour des
associations d'ailleurs vous avez
travaillé pour le théâtre Edouard VII
récemment sur la pièce de de Johnny
Hallyday malheureusement
malgré les emplois successifs que vous
pouvez trouver votre dégradation
physique s'accélère ce qui entraîne
toujours des moqueries et des
humiliations il y a une phrase qui vous
reste est un couple qui vous dit un jour
dans la rue comme ça tu as vu la tête
qu'il a quoi et c'est déjà c'est
mais moi j'ai envie de répondre à ces
gens-là est-ce que vous pensez à ce que
moi je ressens que ce soit un enfant une
adulte à la douleur elle est là mais
effectivement
lorsqu'il s'agit d'adulte et en
l'occurrence la femme de ce couple était
obèse je me dis elle qui doit être
victime des discriminations
ose faire ce genre de réflexion
effectivement
ne pas répondre à ces gens-là ça vous
l'avez jamais oublié non j'ai des
problèmes terribles à l'époque parce
qu'évidemment votre maladie s'aggrave
c'est des problèmes pour vous raser vous
êtes obligé de tirer sur votre peau à
cause des replis et vous dites c'était
comme passé un rasoir sur une boule de
chewing-gum
et il me fallait tirer très fort sur la
pompe pour que le rasage soit
et puis en 2007 vous regardez France 2
vous voyez un documentaire sur Pascal
donc qui a été opérée par le professeur
Lantieri qui était victime comme vous
d'une neurofibromatose et qui a
bénéficié donc d'une greffe de visage
une grève de face comme vous dites à
l'hôpital Henri Mondor de Créteil et là
vous êtes avec votre mère avec votre
temps tu es tout le monde a vite vite
notez le nom du professeur on va
l'appeler Lantieri vous mettez quand
même deux mois à décrocher votre
téléphone parce que vous aviez été déçu
dans pas par toutes les opérations
chirurgicales qui avaient été faites
vous dites celle-là qu'est-ce que ça va
être de plus en gros et mon
interrogation
c'était sympa si c'était une technique
qui était
adoptée à toutes les personnes ici ça
les remplir quand même des
caractéristiques bien particulières vous
voulez savoir aussi si c'était définitif
exactement alors fin 2009
contre votre maladie atteint la totalité
du visage donc le professeur d'ancieni
vous met sur une liste d'attente et le
26 juin 2010
vous êtes en voiture près de
Brive-la-Gaillarde vous recevez un appel
du professeur Lantieri qui vous dit il y
a un demeur à Lyon il faut se tenir près
alors là vous arrêtez à la première gare
pour prendre le TGV pour Paris mais vous
dites j'étais dans un état second
c'est une sensation très étrange parce
que je vais des centaines et des
centaines de pensées qui arrivent en
même temps donc je n'avais pas peur mais
les manifestations physiques de la
prévention était là
immobile et que le monde de toi donnera
les à 2300 à l'heure alors dans la nuit
du 26 au 27 juin 2010
l'opération a lieu donc le professeur
d'antiry nous l'a raconté dans la
première partie de cette émission et il
revient de l'hôpital Édouard Herriot de
Lyon avec dans une boîte le la face
visage du donneur vous vous avez été
préparé à l'hôpital Henri Mondor à
Créteil et on vous fait une grève totale
de la face avec paupières et système
lacrymase qui n'avait jamais été réalisé
auparavant
l'opération va durer 20 heures quand
même
au réveil vous avez un nouveau visage
qui n'est ni votre ancien visage ni le
visage de votre donneur puisque votre
squelette est différent
quand vous découvrez votre nouveau
visage ça n'a pas été facile oui vous
vouliez pas trop vous avez un peu hésité
quand même oui j'ai le souvenir d'avoir
hésité
à plusieurs reprises
il a bien fallu un moment de décider
parce que la pension était malgré tout
présente qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que je vais voir et lorsque le
professeur m'a présenté le miroir malgré
les hématomes malgré les agrafes j'ai vu
que le résultat qui est je dirais même
pas la hauteur
conventionnelle c'était au delà de ce
que j'imaginais mais dans le bon sens du
terme alors à ce moment-là vous ne
pouvez pas parler vous ne pouvez pas
sourire là vous faites comme ça voilà et
il a compris que je suis content c'était
réussi alors aujourd'hui c'est comment
la vie Jérôme
de la nuit au jour
dès mes premières sorties
j'ai vu dans le regard des gens
que l'opération était riche était à la
hauteur de mes espérances parce que
il me regardait mais d'un petit coup
d'œil quand même n'importe qui regarde
n'importe qui et on vit la personne
selon
les quelques personnes qui me
regardaient avec insistance merci les
personnes qui m'avaient reconnu
était très médiatique et alors quels
sont vos relations avec le professeur
Lantier pour vous c'est quand même c'est
Dieu non
j'ai pris une image qui m'est venue il
m'en voudra pas j'espère pour moi ça a
été comme une bête sauvetage dans le
sens
j'ai tout de suite eu confiance
en vous allez professeur et toute son
équipe parce que il a une équipe
formidable
et je me sentais en train de même donc
je me suis laissé aller et j'ai une
immense reconnaissance
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu